police work is tough man you know a lot
of officers retiring don't live a year
after retirement
because of stress from day in day out
over 20 years dealing with the [ __ ] the
city offers you in baltimore city you
work 20 times harder than any other
jurisdiction it's just a fact i don't
think people have any idea they have no
clue
[Music]
big h and dre two career baltimore
police officers they've both been in
flex team task forces plainclothes units
and they're truly two of the best of
baltimore's finest baltimore is a city
that was known as the murder capital of
the country you know that police
department was just ravished with
corruption and now that i've become very
close with these unbelievable people who
have been a part of that police
department through all of that i am
truly blessed to to be doing what i'm
doing i think you guys feel the same way
about what you do absolutely and i just
you know the the people that you meet
along the way and uh yeah i said before
you know one of the criteria about being
on the show is i gotta love you and i
love you all man i love you brothers and
and uh the connection was immediate the
respect that you garner among your peers
among your fellow officers in baltimore
is staggering the way in which i've seen
the community react to you guys is
beautiful it's respect and it's love
and uh it's just an honor i'm really i'm
really appreciative that you guys are
here man how did you two meet
oh man we've been in the academy but we
wasn't like no cause in the academy like
i got an academy in 2011.
were you were you both in together yes
yeah just different classes i was in
like eleven one once yeah i want like
first impressions too because i know how
i'm yours as close as [ __ ] can
get like you guys are going to do that
like
right yeah go ahead because uh i was in
1101 using 1103 right
and so it's the 2011 i was the first
academy class he was in 1103 the third
academy class so when i got out in the
streets i was assigned to the northeast
district
he got on the streets he was assigned to
any district he was down he was he was
assigned to a downtown unit yeah they go
he'll tell his part but then he came to
the northeast what like two years later
yeah
and then once he got to the northeast he
was assigned to sector two
which is another sector in the northeast
can you describe the northeast for
people the northeast is the biggest
district in the city it covers about 9.2
miles okay and it's the largest district
in the city that deals with any and
everything okay we have residential
homes we got the home you know the hood
we have everything universal of
everything huh we have a university
there yes uh morgan state is that shout
out to them in northeast
yep so pretty much the northeast that's
why i had all my trainees i want them to
learn in northeast
because you learn your white collar
crimes you learn your armed robberies
you learn your shootings your cuttings
your stabbing your domestics you get
everything you can hone in your skill
set as an officer working in northeast
district it's the biggest district
you're going to have a high core rate
volume but you're going to learn how to
write
only way to do this job is by getting
out there and learning how to write
reports and that's how you build that's
how you build
your police skill set straight up and
and and building rapport with people
interacting with people you know some
people are shy cool get out there yeah
put them with a seasoned vet that can
teach them the ropes yep yep yep you
ain't you never you never been to an
inner city you've never been to a hood
block where they selling
get out there and talk to them that's it
that's the only way you can get past
that that nervousness
if you never interacted with it before
okay go with a seasoned guy that could
put you out there and you could talk to
these people and that's where you met
dre you met him in the northeast i met
him in the north well i met in the
academy but we didn't converse like that
okay until we got an annoyance we in the
academy would just give each other head
nods because like we'll be working out
together right and we'll just be
beasting through the workouts yeah yeah
yeah and then when i got to the
northeast i was downtown
i was um
i was respectfully escorted out of a
unit yeah they respectfully told him he
had to go
why's that baby
he was showing off i didn't i didn't do
i didn't do something that they wanted
me to do what they want you to do
um
they wanted me to stay there
and like
just just to be there like
just being on and then shout out to
everybody that walked foot
we woke a foot and i got into a walking
foot meeting doing your patrol
yeah yeah you know i see these guys they
ride around in cars yeah you know what
i'm saying they call them [ __ ]
the bumblebees and [ __ ] daddy
little orange vests and [ __ ] around well
i can't have the glow faster it's funny
you said my partner owns this city i
can't imagine with an orange vest
now we had an orange vest right so we
did everything with like
crowd control
drugs
they were hands-on with that yeah we
were hands on like we put up no lock we
put up a thousand arrests
in like six months yeah the group of us
damn so all we knew was drugs like drug
arrests when i got to the northeast
shout out to lieutenant dw
um
i'm writing
child abuses i'm writing
um that t-step [ __ ] had to write
reports all over again i had to learn
yeah
how to learn because i didn't do that
down there for two years i never wrote a
child abuse report right right so
shout out to a dw lieutenant
he would take my reports and like like
school
hit it with red paper red ink yeah and
just be like you got to rewrite this
yeah yeah yeah yeah stand with my [ __ ]
yeah what to make it a better case to
make it play better in court or do it
the right way the right way it wasn't
like garbage and he checked me he's like
no you're gonna be here like he's saying
in the northeast you're gonna get you're
gonna get everything you know certain
places that you only deal with
you know drugs
certain places you only deal with
uh
lost need from all those right
residential burglaries right you know
what i'm saying no feast gives you that
collection of everything but i'll tell
you
how me and him first started working
together we in the chum chilling
chum is a spot each other it's a heavy
drug area
okay that's a dope
the chum it's like five six blocks
of pure just drug drugs and it's always
every every other block is that like
that one way this way one with the other
way this way
majority of it got tore down because it
was so notorious but
we're there with the silverbacks the
originals
and um him and i we get
a dirt bike it was a dirt bike arrest
and the way him and i not working
together but we know each other from the
academy
we were communicating and it worked out
so well that that was our first arrest
together yeah so it's super hard in this
town to get a dirt bike that's like a
unicorn yeah wow wow dirt bikes are so
mint like they could get on sidewalks
yeah they could get up on uh you know
like
off-road terrain they can get low quick
they're good and they're fine depending
on the rider yeah right there's some
riders that are sick as [ __ ] around here
yeah yeah he wasn't one of those guys
tell me what happened so
they call it out and dirt bike is like
it's like it's like you know when a dog
sees a cat yeah yeah it's like what yeah
that [ __ ] is like a unicorn oh why you
you because if you see because the dirt
bike violation is hard to get yeah and
there's no pursuit policy in in the city
so you can't chase him at the time you
can't chase him at all the cards okay
that's the [ __ ]
you just not the time we quit chasing
them yeah now again now now we can by
the time we could it was all free game
yeah so this guy's running through the
charm him and we're communicating
communicating we get the guy because a
lot of times with dirt bikes
they'll ditch him uh-huh and then they
get away yeah so it's like i just got a
bike yeah how do you stop a dirt bike
you can't
so how did you well how we did is
we driving
you know i turned the overheads off
because i don't want a muffler
yeah we like when we go straight turn
the lights off and are you guys in the
same car in the same car but how did you
guys end up in the same car
we were short of the car the car okay so
they're like you two right right
together okay boom and i'm like fake was
[ __ ] sealed that day boo yeah let's
go okay so then what happens so the call
comes out there's a yellow and white
dirt bike i got a picture of you got a
picture of you
so that's like your baby that's like
your child i love you guys i love the
bikes it's not the first one we got
either okay okay so what happened so
i was driving at night was that driving
you was driving
because i think you got him you got
because you went on foot right
yeah
no i think i was driving you was driving
i got him on foot he got
so we heard him i hit the dirt bike
because he is he's the runner
wow i get on my horse and that's that's
as big as he is he's the runner we'll
talk about that lately play football in
college absolutely i didn't know that oh
until i saw it yeah oh yeah another
story yeah yeah i'm like you're running
yeah yeah yeah so now so we heard it and
then we seen it
so i'm like all right so he's like i see
your pull out i said pull over i'm just
going i'm gonna go around the corner
we're following the sound the foundation
we're like yo he made a left he made it
right
and
as soon as i get out the car i go behind
the butt like i'm in the alley
so i go around and i heard him but he
started [ __ ] up the gears yeah so i
knew he wasn't experienced i said god
he didn't see me because i get his
stealth mode when you know when the
hunter's on yeah i turned my radio low i
wanted my [ __ ] head nothing yeah yeah
so i get around the corner and he's
sitting there trying to kick it i said
get the [ __ ] on the floor yeah yeah yeah
he looked at me and just like he got
shook yeah and then he just the bike
dropped and he ain't even run and i
because i was on him i was right there
yeah yeah there's a whole lot of right
there too with him yeah yeah you know
yeah
the guard comes seriously but um
but now he complies he complies
put the cuffs on him that was it yeah it
wasn't no putting hands over here
he was a gentleman right yeah we didn't
hit him we didn't curse it was a simple
arrest but on that day i get like when
yeah then this [ __ ] takes the
dirt bikes and spins it around the block
yeah i was writing [ __ ] he picked it up
and everything
was like yeah
i mean now you got a guy in uniform
right
right in the dirt bike and the hood
loved it
and you guys have love for the hood of
course
yeah when you come from it they embrace
you that [ __ ] run through us
like when did you know that that was a
cat
that you could trust
like when did you know that that was a
guy that had your back
it all started that night we've been
writing since then since then it's been
what 10 years no no 11 no we got 11 on
it's been nine years nine years yeah
since we write them together can you
give me an example
uh any kind of example of when h has
really been there for you we're in the
four by four yeah right
four by four is another four blocks it's
four blocks it's like that famous hood
in l.a yeah that they film all the time
jungle
in compton i guess where they did um
training day training day yeah yeah like
one way in one way
four by four yeah call it four by four
super famous in this town
we got a domestic call
and um this dude's a pretty big dude
and she's upset she wants him out
out
so i show up
right
i'm primary because it's my post and
he's just my backup yeah right and he
did what he was supposed to do
he sees that me and the guy
were bumping heads
because he's like
short little [ __ ] what you [ __ ]
with and i'm like why are you talking to
me i hear a hot head all right i'm like
this i'm like this
i'm like what i'm like separating like
what what are we doing yeah i'm i'm
completely forgetting my profession yeah
yeah right yeah he checks me oh
i got it i got it
and the conversation with that gentleman
with him
these guys are walking out like they
were best friends
if he would not be there yeah i it would
have it would have gone nasty because he
was obviously he was like what six he
was like six three six four
so he was wide though just came home
just came home
found this lady doing something she
wasn't supposed to do yeah and on one
and now here i am
showing up telling him
hey man man like you got to come with me
you put your hands on this lady yeah
right yeah he wasn't feeling that
so to prevent
everyone
from getting hurt especially me i knew
let me fall back my ego right yeah
i'm humbled let me fall back and if he
could get a better outcome let him work
the case he has a certain way
he walked in there and he was like oh
what's up big [ __ ] yeah and the
dude was like what so now you got two
big dudes
and he got him to
calm down he got him to your main man
you don't really want to do this yeah
like they spoke on a level that i
couldn't get them there yeah and
sometimes with police work
we called it i talked him in the cups
yeah talked to me he walked them into
the cops yeah absolutely with no problem
yeah
yeah cause you know that's not a lot of
every man has an ego
and then him just coming home
you know big dude
to me that never meant [ __ ]
because you got to bring ass to get ass
but at the end of the day you gotta know
how to talk to people straight up
because it's not about that
in this profession
you have to have the certain temperament
to deal with people
and be professional even when you're
dealing with somebody that's ignorant
talk to me about the importance of of
training and talk to me about uh you
know i know that that's a that's a huge
part of of of your life and what you do
what makes a good trainer and just talk
to me about preparation why it's so
important i think h could
answer that because
the biggest thing you know preparation
is key because it's not if but when
something happens
training
with some people you know training in
general it's a perishable skill if you
don't do
it and then this line of work you don't
got time for that straight up
as you can see there's a lot of people
that you know killing the badges right
now
making their own individual choices
instead of doing what does that mean
killing the badges by making their own
personal decisions instead of making
decisions based off of what you were
taught and trained to do and the oath
that you took and the oath that you took
being the agent of your department is
paramount in your success in policing
[ __ ] tend to do what they want
to do forget about what you was taught
and groomed to do there lies the issue
there lies the problem that's why
there's always a dark cloud under law
enforcement
all around the country
because some officers tend to do what
they want to do instead of what they're
trained to do it was an individual
choice
choice and when we and when we make
these decisions a lot of times it's
instantaneously
and with ego yeah yeah yeah
there's a lot of [ __ ] that walk
around with the bats and think they're
god yeah no you're nuts what do you
think it says about people when they are
unable to admit that they're [ __ ] up
to admit that they have flaws because i
feel like you can't learn that you hit a
wall until you until you admit that you
hit that wall absolutely so
i am
that is a personal thing
so that's not the academy that's not the
profession that is an individual thing
like that officer that made that mistake
yeah
he needs to go in the mirror yeah look
at himself and check himself
his co-workers need to check him how
would how would you check him if you if
if he was one of your i mean i didn't
pull them aside but what the [ __ ] are
you doing why are you talking people i'm
like listen go sit in the car yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's no longer your car
and have you guys been in that situation
absolutely tell me about just baltimore
in general i came down here like you
guys are both new yorkers right yeah
it's dope though you say that um we we
just came out with like a dope t-shirt
right hardest city by the sea yeah we
were listening one day we was listening
to
to uh
to nina simone in triple c studio shout
out to triple c
you know he's our engineer all that
gushing
and which is like vibing right and nina
simone said in her baltimore song that
baltimore was the hardest city by the
sea so we took that beautiful right as a
tribute to this beautiful town this this
town is so beautiful but like you like
you were explaining the other day
there's a certain
brutal aspect to whatever but there's
also beauty to it when you was talking
about russia they always go hand in hand
don't they it goes hand in hand yeah so
as a society
we need to realize that it goes
hand-in-hand what do you love about this
city i love i love the colorful
everything about this i love everything
like downtown is amazing this town on
the low
it's small but it feels big yeah it has
it's certain pockets yeah that is like
yo what you're doing down there but then
it's beautiful like here yeah
shout out to monarch right here
what what what frustrates you about
baltimore
it's a
you know what i'll let him talk about
that
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey the king of the kid you know he
knows how to talk i don't i don't do
politics neither do we we don't we don't
do politics keep politics out of
policing what's 100 percent my thing is
this i feel like if i've heard one thing
over the last month and a half that's
what i've heard the most keep politics
two different games straight up two
different games my thing is
let us know what you want us to do
i could play any game you want me to
play just game and give me the rules to
it
i don't take [ __ ] personal
i'm good on that this is business yeah
let me know what you want done and we'll
do it
period
speaking of business like sometimes he
gets at me i get at him we get at him he
gets at us yeah it's all love yeah it's
business yeah yeah so let's move forward
so we could continue to like put the
best product out there
the town needs to do that put the
bs to the side
and give the people the best baltimore
everybody needs to be on the same page
yeah i think everybody politically
needs to be on the same page because
this
the city is amazing it could be oh man
like it's it could be almost a minute in
new york well you know what like the
hoodies to act accordingly too it ain't
just you know the people downtown the
hood needs to act accordingly too they
would need to act accordingly but you
can't we need them to say we need them
to be able to press the button
to send gorillas to do gorilla work
straight
can you go into that
i would love to
police work
is not easy
that's not pretty
we make this [ __ ] look easy
by what we do how we are as individuals
police work is tough man
a lot of [ __ ] don't have no
clue what police work you know a lot of
officers retiring don't live a year
after retirement
because of stress because of the stress
because of drinking
failed marriages
from day in day out over 20 years
dealing with the [ __ ] the city offers
you
nobody that's the stuff that's behind
the curtain
that nobody and this and it's cool you
don't have to care i get it but it's a
reality
in baltimore city you work 20 times
harder than any other jurisdiction it's
just a fact you're so experienced
because of all the [ __ ] because
everything you go through it's constant
yeah yeah yeah constant i don't think
people have any idea they have no clue
no idea do you think any good out of the
like all the scrutiny that police are
under right now do you think any good
can come out of that yeah us
explain 100
what we do
because what we do we get out there we
hands-on we talk to people we have
change what is an example of a
quote-unquote a member of the criminal
element something that you've seen them
do that you absolutely respect check it
the first time we went to the west side
north and penn
i took him there
what's up pencil north pennsylvania
yeah the block is
but the hood is hood anyway you go right
yeah
so we're in north from pennsy
me and dre
we on foot right after the riots right
after the riots they're like yo keep
this corner
the traffic is gonna is gonna be here
you can't do [ __ ] about it crystal clear
keep it clear just keep it clear from
one side just never have keep walking to
other side
we bump into the head guy
that runs that entire organization
gentlemen we shoot the shipment where
you're from we're from new york we talk
he came up to us he came up to us we
didn't know who he was because if you
see him he was just a fly dude in the
hood right glasses all right clean clean
gucci gucci polo wow feel me
on this [ __ ] let us drip
he came up to us like let me talk to
y'all yeah
we talking he said he said listen
be honest with you i did some time no
doubt
i got i got a couple bags of wheat on me
right now i said we're not here for that
mm-hmm
the way he looked at us
and the way we was conversing
he said damn
i got y'all what did you do
he picked the shades up yeah he's
because he was talking to the shades he
put the shades up he looked us in the
eye was like i gotcha
he was like
yo
yeah when i tell you to block hey yo it
must have been like 50 people
disappeared disappeared
i was like what what
you know one of the things that we talk
about and and again
part of the reason why i'm trying to do
what i'm doing is i'm trying to give the
microphone to people who have actually
walked the walk right because too many
of these conversations are led by people
have no idea what the [ __ ] that is
right i appreciate that hey look man
you're amazing bro
platform i love it man that's the world
needs for like yes right now people to
hear you know what i'm saying but i
think one of the things when you have
these sort of like armchair
psychiatrists and these [ __ ]
are trying to dissect the situation they
talk about the blue line they talk about
this loyalty and i think look i think
oftentimes what's wonderful about an
institution or about a person or about
anything is also often a close cousin to
what's also toxic about them and what's
damaging about them and i'm just
wondering how do you guys feel about
loyalty in the police force and can you
give me examples of fierce loyalty when
it's at its most beautiful and it's most
righteous and have you ever seen loyalty
go astray and and and not work
um that's a dope-ass question man it's
gross but the premise for what we do
is we hold everybody accountable
i love this profession
i'm never gonna let a bad seed go
through
if a [ __ ] did something
yo let's go
you gotta you gotta be accounted for you
gotta go deal with it
i'm not gonna have that around me
because if i don't say something i'm
gonna get jammed up straight up
and there's been times when
[ __ ] outcast people
it don't matter to me at the end of the
day
i'm here to do what's best for this
department
and as a man i'm not gonna let nobody
[ __ ] that up i'm not gonna let nobody
[ __ ] my name and you're not gonna let
anybody [ __ ] up the community absolutely
not that's the other thing that i see
because what what i've what i've really
come to learn especially being here
because i think this department as we
know have been through a lot of [ __ ] man
there have been some janky [ __ ]
who have really but what i've seen is
nobody is hurt more by corrupt policing
than the police themselves
and that's something that's just like
this wild thing that i think nobody
really knows it is like the corruption
that took place in the city
has really set back
great police officers and it set back
great policing you want to know what
great officers hate
bad officers dirty [ __ ] with
that loyalty thing because i heard like
you know your episode with fenton which
i thought was was was really brilliant
just like it's awesome
shout out to jess
and
a real secret
even as [ __ ] and a seeker of truth in a
world that only wants you to be that
that's concerned with optics and how
things look and pandering he feels like
he's really after the truth man he's
based on his profession
he's a true you know there's true police
there's true everything he's a true
journalist i have some mad respect for
him but one of the things that i heard
you guys say
is that it's not about going
it's not about going and turning
somebody in it's not about going to ied
it's not really about that it's about
checking them yourself and having a
situation yeah can you guys explain that
if it's something like minute if if you
curse somebody out yeah what the [ __ ]
you doing you can't do that bro right
right right because because you're gonna
get jammed up right yeah you'll lose
your job over something so stupid right
you know don't don't don't lose your
cool over somebody that's being rude and
negative to you right you're the
professional
people look at you like you're here to
do a job and serve right
you're supposed to bring that individual
from a ten down to a five yeah and then
once you bring him down to a five let
him realize what he did wrong yeah
and that's how you build rapport yeah
and that's how that individual will
appreciate you at the end of the day
that's right you know what i'm saying i
do i do
my in my experiences i've always told
people that like
you know you might get a kid
first time he got a gun
he thinks he's the man
so he thinks he can talk to certain
people a certain way
and i'm like yo you know how many guns
are on this block
that you won't even know right now right
put that away
right and this is me checking him like
listen
it's all about respect
you talk to certain people a certain way
i said you don't need this this is just
a tool
what i'm saying and they got to be ready
and willing to accept that check cause
i'm checking you because if you keep
thinking oh i'm a tough guy and i'm
gonna go to the gun and all this [ __ ]
you're gonna find yourself in a really
bad situation absolutely because that's
not what really what it's about it's
about talking how can i help you
cause you called me right you down 9-1-1
you're having a bad day yeah i can't
show up and that's the problem right
cause if i'm having a bad day personally
right my wife
is out there doing something or my
spouse whatever my kids are willing i
can't bring that to work yeah i got to
be clear minded but it's also it's a
human professional people go through
[ __ ] and you ask that's what people
don't understand that yes we show up and
we put the uniform on we're not robots
like we have feelings we have and we
have to be
strong-minded to check that [ __ ] at the
door have roll call and whatever but but
with that hot button and and apologize
that this is uncomfortable
but like when you when you take george
floyd like taking that situation we've
all seen the video i want to [ __ ] every
one of them officers up but like
is so disrespectful and just that's that
is
the that is so bad for policing
bro
you're not taught to do that to anybody
how do you put your knee on the back of
somebody's neck that was what the [ __ ]
that's not a control technique yo that i
guarantee you was an individual he did
what he wanted to do that's nothing but
what are you
but what do you what how do you feel
about those other officers that did they
should get time too because the
[ __ ] sat there and watched that
man die wow so and will there be people
on this force people that you police
with that have a problem with what you
just said no they say do [ __ ] [ __ ]
them for me [ __ ] them for me that's real
as [ __ ] you already know for me and they
know how i operate the guard is serious
i don't play that stuff
i i like see for me i'm in that aspect
he too pro police i'm not no no no no
it's not that's not that
it's not that it's just
i was upset from a human aspect
like i get that the fact that it was
their first day on the job but it's like
as a human as a human yeah you should
know that's wrong you should know that's
wrong you don't have to go to academy to
know that that was wrong
thank you that's a human what what so so
what do you as a human you know and as
an expert as career police officers
legendary police officers in this city
what do you think
was the mindset
of derek's show like what was in his
mind that day i'll you know what and i i
know we can't know for sean i don't know
but i you can tell yeah what do you see
there you can tell that he's been
he's been in that culture
for the longest time the way he can do
what he wants to do what is that culture
a [ __ ] culture for policing yeah yeah
yeah explain it not listen
not obeying yeah the policies and
procedures set forth for him to police
yeah yeah but he took his offender yeah
yeah he wanted to do what the [ __ ] he
wanted to do which is a lot of cops go
rogue they get it it only take but one
small thing to get away with yeah yeah
then you start feeling yourself you feel
you got a big dick you can run around
and do what you want to do but what and
but what is that mentality is it is it a
me version i think it's a lot of
[ __ ] that have been that was
put in high school that's what see that
that's what i see that's bullied there's
trust me like just a bitch-ass
[ __ ] that couldn't help with the
guard you couldn't chill with me at the
cool table in high school so you figured
you'd get it bad to start bullying
[ __ ] yeah yeah it's it's sad
have you seen that here in baltimore
minimal
minimal because those people now you
know what policing is totally different
now but back then
yeah back yeah but now
a lot of people need jobs
so a lot of people come on the job
thinking policing is cool and it's fun
and they can just get a check yeah when
you get out in these streets
it's a total ballgame it's different
ball game yeah yeah cause you know you
got that nipple in your mouth when
you're in the academy yeah and you
sucking on that thing you're good
you feel like oh man i got this
[ __ ] this this full milk yeah
yeah take care of me baby
no two percent [ __ ] up right
but when you're getting
sick
you know you're being cuddled you know
but now but when you get in the streets
it's different yeah nothing can prepare
you for the [ __ ] until you get into it
yep yep i don't i don't care what block
you are where you at the streets will
humble you all day somebody gonna humble
you yeah 100
yeah yeah but you know it's it's you
know why it's tough because this stand
is this qualifications if you pass it
you pass you know you won't know until
you actually in it yeah you know what
i'm saying they could prepare you as
much as they can
you know
do movies do do film through lectures do
people coming in to talk to you and to
prepare you mentally but once you see
them streets and you got to interact
with these people yeah
like
how are you going to feel from if you
tell somebody so you got i need you to
and if you start stuttering here already
no you scared yeah yep they said i need
you to clear the car to get the [ __ ] out
of it they smell it they're going what
you gonna do let me ask you something
before you come on please before you
guys came on the force yeah
you ever been in a street fight before
that your [ __ ] ride you ever
put your hands on something dick b this
is official straight up how about you
i did more than just fight
so
how much experience would you say you
had in your life with violence before
you became a police officer a lot a lot
right you that that was a that was a
world in which you
feel comfortable with but
you know what it's it's
i think it's it's it it's sad but it's a
gift
it's absolutely look man experience
period you've got one game
yes and like thank for the grace of god
praise the lord everyone is here you
guys are still here right like like
praise the lord you got out of whatever
you got into right but you've been down
that road before and when someone puts
his hands on you you know it's you you
you've been there before you know
what percentage would you say i mean you
you train officers you're training
officers in the academy when you're
training officers when people are coming
to look to you what percentage of those
cats that come to you have had violence
in their life before i have had some
experience with that none of them very
small very small very small so my
question is like
you know because for me like i i don't
know how to get into
derek shovin's mindset that's that's
he's exhibiting something that i don't
really
understand now them other dudes who
didn't do [ __ ] i see some scared people
right i've seen people make mistakes
okay i'm gonna i'm i'm like look i've
never walked that walk so who am i to to
know what it's like to walk around the
streets in a uniform with a gun i don't
know but when i see somebody going to
their gun
when maybe they could use their hands
the only thing i think of is okay that
person must be afraid that person isn't
just there's some hands were got on that
they didn't know what to do so bam right
okay so what kind of techniques what
kind of tools can you give them to sort
of deal with that fear and how much do
you think fear plays a part
of bad decisions a lot of it a lot of it
because if fear
everybody's gonna be nervous everybody
and then everybody's fear is different
right and you're not gonna know how
you're gonna react to something until
you're in that situation but you know
what you know what
what would
contrast that training well that's it i
mean the first time you go in the ocean
you got i don't care who you are you can
be scared as a [ __ ] you keep
going every day all of a sudden you're
swimming in those waves so when you hear
somebody say come up with an idea hey
let's defund the police
that's the that's the wrong tactic right
so so so really what it is is let's put
more funding in more training if this is
what you want right if society wants
this type of service yeah then we need
more funding right it's about
hand-to-hand i wanted to implement
boxing but that's above my pay grade
right
boxing is paramount hand the hell
grappling that's huge jujitsu you know
what i'm saying it's so dumb that you
said that because
if you're proficient i'm proficient with
the hands-on yeah i don't need to go you
don't need to go to the gun work at all
i don't need that how much would you say
is the average the average police
officer on the streets of baltimore how
much hand-to-hand combat training would
you say they have in a year none unless
they do it personally right now you have
to train personally yeah and they have
to and like
why is that
it's
so short-handed yeah
they need bodies on the streets that's
the
red tape that we can't cross because
it's
out of there it's out of our element but
there's
a lot of officers that go to the range
on their own yeah they pay their own
money a lot of them go do
yeah and these guys are the most
peaceful people you want to say
absolutely well i think there's a huge
misconception about people who are
training all the time that they're
actually looking to engage in those
situations and i think it's really
interesting only if you've been down
that road do you know it's actually the
complete opposite yeah if you're
training off you don't train just to get
in the [ __ ] i mean look i'm trying to
see you can get out of it so you don't
need to go there and if you can defuse
it quickly bruce lee was the
the pillar of that right yeah yeah he
always took people out of it like
you don't want this right please with
baby
cut son he said with baby
can y'all just explain flex unit jump
out boys can you and i know that that's
how you use soraka you just explain
what's that kind of it's an aggressive
element of police work yep where
men are just hunting men
so like in patrol we're answering calls
now there's a problem once you get out
of patrol
now you get into that element of i'm
only focusing on drugs and guns
so like if i have a hot corner right
like a corner where there's a lot of
violence
there's a certain group of men and shout
out to all of them and women that do
this job every day because there's a
50-50 chance that they could get shot
back in the day we could approach them
and be like yo what's up
what you got on you
and then that's how you get guns so they
were clever they were like i'm not gonna
carry on me i'm gonna leave it here i'm
gonna hide it i'm gonna do certain
things hands-on policing is done
that [ __ ] is over but it's needed
it's needed it's gonna serve a purpose
in mind
is there anything
is there anything about hands-on jumping
out flex unit uh jump out board type
type you got so much drugs off the
streets you got so much guns off the
streets tell me you stopped murders you
stopped it was a huge it was a drastic
change i'd say the last time we've been
over 300 homicides and how long do i the
last what six years
yeah
the last time it was what one something
197 197 2011 right
back when it was hands on numbers may be
wrong but that's so around the ball look
at the bottom line his lives were like
you less
killed right yes okay but would you also
agree would you also agree yeah and i'm
i'm i'm throwing this out here now cause
i know this is a question yes sir but
that the majority of
uh the potential for corruption and the
potential for police doing bad are in
those units is that is that a is that a
uh is that a true sentiment or or not
you sentiment
you know what that's that's a good
question it is a great question it's a
great question i don't i don't know well
when i asked when i go down to the the
pueblo bishop housing projects in in in
in south central at the time yes because
those [ __ ] are arrested when i
talk to people who are on the other side
right good people yeah what they say is
their main beef with the police
is that their youngsters are sitting
around the corners doing their thing and
[ __ ] are coming up throwing
them up against a car throw them up
against the wall searching their [ __ ]
calm this this and that i i i think and
as the people who grew up in those kinds
of neighborhoods and maybe you've had
those kinds of experience with the
police how do you guys feel because
because that is that
no you you're absolutely true i agree
i think it's i think you know what
when you give
when you give a [ __ ] rope
sometimes they hang themselves with it
it's a human profession
so there's great police that was doing
the job to a t
in that time frame but also it was ones
that just doing extra just because they
know they could do it straight up so i
agree with that assessment because even
i've i've seen it growing up
where police would just be [ __ ] and
abuse the authority because they can
right and they think this [ __ ] is cool
just small dick my phone you know
exactly short dick in their whole life
that's right and they got the girth to
mess her up but anyhoo yeah you know and
it [ __ ] with them mentally yeah so
they figured they won't take that out on
anybody else but with cats like you and
you and when i talked to like my boy
when we talked to maggio yeah yeah shout
out to him
you talk about a dude who is in it for
the whole right reasons why i'm gonna
police the way i'm gonna police and i'm
out here because i grew up in this
community
and i write and he's like i and like i
am going to take the fight to the bad
guys but i still do it with empathy care
and compassion for the community that i
police in but the bottom line that is
inarguable that i feel like what you
guys are saying what i'm hearing from
from both the police
and honestly from the element on the
other side what i keep hearing is that
look at the end of the day murder rates
are skyrocketing crime is skyrocketing
because you're taking those units off
the street so what's the answer and in
my in my opinion
it's it's amplifying and let's instead
of just spending all this time and i
understand that's necessary looking at
these people who [ __ ] up and terrible
depri depraved deprived awful [ __ ] let's
look at the [ __ ] who are doing
it right like let's look at the dudes
who are policing hard so to add to what
he's saying and i agree with that but
also let's look at the flip side of the
coin right those guys in the pueblo
bishop right
a lot of them i don't know any of them
you know shout out to them or whatever
straight up
and if you say they with it i believe
you because i'm with you you're with us
yeah yes right
but how many of them
are just like hey
this guy hemming me up for no reason
like every on both sides we have to take
ownership straight up so you can't cry
if you out there slinging and you
poisoning your community and you out
there with the banger and you blowing
and you send it you put orders in
you can't really complain when the
police pull up on you and they talk and
they check you straight up you can't
complain straight up cause you out here
tell me about policing before and after
the the the body camera and the cell
phone and what roles they play you know
what
but prior pre-body camera of course they
would just
take it for what it's worth whatever was
documented you know what i'm saying and
there was so much gray area well i
didn't do this i didn't do that
what by word
yeah it sees everything so when the
suspect will say no i didn't do that you
said they're all here on footage sure
like certain camera yeah it's on camera
so everything is there for the public
even for the public to say
in some cases oh he was he was going to
college he was going to
stop no doubt
i get it but it's on the camera
that's what you wanted right that's what
you wanted so this is i love the body on
camera because it shows them how some
people can be ignorant yeah it shows the
real life of what an officer goes
through yeah how he's being spoken to
yeah
yeah on the regular yeah
on top of everything and you know it's
crazy they see that [ __ ] that's crazy
there's no empathy towards police
officers they don't give a [ __ ] about
police officers that's how many bodies
no we can go yo we could go to a call
our first call or be a shooting after we
cleared it up go to homicide i'll be
back tonight in service
how about a [ __ ] child abuse
how about how about a girl being killed
throat being cut
all on body cameras all on body wall all
blood we see blood organs every
meanwhile meanwhile you gotta you got
your daughter calling you hey dad i just
wanted to call you and say good night
are you thinking about your kid like and
you see and you think about this
teenager that was just stuffed in this
[ __ ] storm now you and i you know
like the homicides shout out to 2100 wow
they got to go inform that family and
give them that bad news
you know what i'm saying and think about
that and then go home to their own kids
all day you go home and your kids you i
yo you know how many times i go home and
i'm hugging my kids
and i'm just like
it's crazy because of the [ __ ] we see
there's no such thing as a regular
eight-hour day
every eight hour day no matter how much
overtime you do no matter what district
you at
every hour is different
[ __ ] just changes
and just tried doing that for 15 20
years
you think you're a sane person you're
changing you're not getting help
and i never
i commend the department because they
are
units now that that are strictly
designed to take care of ask that
officer to get help with
to seek help to speak with somebody yo
to be an officer in this city i love it
i'll never take it back i will always be
a board of muslims but any all cities
involved you go through it you go
through it mentally on top of what
you're doing in your personal life and
then you got to deal with you know the
job at hand you got to be built for it
yeah yeah all right but but but now
there's this new element of what which
is every time you guys get out of the
car
you got a cell phone on you and you got
hey you guys are the enemy like and
that's this new i mean i know there's
always probably been a certain degree of
that but like right now i mean that's
what we signed up for that shouldn't
bother me yeah but right now they're
capitalizing on it because they know
they could make money off
but every officer that steps out of the
car he knows he's there to do a job we
don't mind body cameras because we we're
following the letter of the law
what he said tell me what you want me to
do
if you change the law i'm gonna i'm
gonna do what the law says i'm game
right it's not personal for me it ain't
personal you know what's personal for me
getting out there talking to these
business owners
talking to everybody because that's what
that's what community you know policing
is
going to the churches talking they're
speaking to everybody that you come
across yeah so that you can eliminate
violence when they see you
when the doughboys see you
because once you talk to them you'll
know their names
right like you build your own little
statue your own little book yeah just
off cause we there you think i'm eight
hours [ __ ] and i mean i was watching
what you're doing
who you're interacting with who comes to
see you at 10 30 in the morning i don't
got to throw the hands with you stop i'm
gonna sit back i'm gonna watch you
ninety percent of the job is talking
period and that only comes that only
comes that's when you have to it does
come with some experience it doesn't
complete confidence yes because you know
it's all about the circle you keep i
keep myself from small i don't have
friends i have brothers
big difference
[Music]
a lot of times you got to teach people
how to treat you no [ __ ] don't
talk to me any kind of way they want
supervisor lieutenant captain
everybody gets slapped in they [ __ ]
face don't talk to me any kind of way
you want yeah cause you're a man i'm a
man because at the end of the day i'm a
king and when i leave and when i take
this uniform off my [ __ ] still gonna
love me for who i am
a lot of these [ __ ] on the job
for their own particular reasons when
they leave that uniform they [ __ ]
when they get out of work
[ __ ] don't respect them pardon my
friends
it's true who are you when you when you
got to put that [ __ ] when you
put that uniform and you got to leave it
and take it off who are you when you get
the [ __ ] out of that district or that
precinct to drive home you know how many
[ __ ] that are scared to retire
or when they retire they don't leave
their house
they tip the windows in every house and
every in
every window of their house because they
don't want to leave that [ __ ] because
all the dirty [ __ ] they did in the
course of their career
i'm real
and when you know real one if you treat
a [ __ ] bad pardon my spitting
you be good man but what's your name
what's real with life
if you treat a [ __ ] bad and you
good with that and you having a good
time because you got a badge
you don't know what that [ __ ]
going to do to you
even if you let him off the hook but you
treating him like [ __ ] don't worry
[ __ ] wait till you get off work to
follow you to know where you live that's
right it's so dope do you know how deep
this [ __ ] get
hey yo i'm telling you [ __ ] is different
but do you think
the reason why the two of you guys can
go into the community treat people with
respect treat people with empathy have
love for everybody in that community see
yourself in everybody in that community
is because
you also have the ability when you're
off duty or even when you're on to go to
places and be completely comfortable in
places
that most people are too afraid to go
100 i'm comfortable anywhere everywhere
we go you put me in africa right now
[Music]
i don't know i'm not feeding online i
ain't [ __ ] i don't know
but guess what the [ __ ] feeding the
lion you give me jesus
i respect them what are the silverbacks
man tell me exactly that like i mean our
logo you see it blue we call him blue
the gorilla he got his eyes blacked out
he don't see no evil you know he's here
to do a job and he's in a suit he's a
gentleman yeah like he said but he's
also gangsta because a
real super back will tell you how it's a
part yeah but you got to get him to that
point we don't want to get to that point
and and and who
the the silverbacks are what they're
they're they're a group they're a group
of troop it's a mentality yeah and it's
the guys we came up with it's it's that
was
we called ourselves the civil backs
because we always took care of each
other we always had each other in line
we always worked out after work we made
sure and you had to work overtime if you
were [ __ ] with us oh yeah that was a
criteria you have to work overtime you
had to work out after the show just had
to this is the new hierarchy of policing
we switching the whole game on some
luxury [ __ ]
sexy we're doing luxury policing what
you know what i'm saying you know what
i'm saying i'm gonna put the hand hold
up hello
what i'm saying i'm gonna put the
handcuffs on you
sophisticated right on
but listen we understand we know but you
know what
we're giving everything to police and we
love it straight up policing is easy to
us it's not hard it's just the
individual [ __ ] yeah yeah we're
agents of our department we love our
department shout out the baltimore city
police department shout out to all
departments all departments worldwide in
the world i know you probably said that
by your profession but yo being a cop is
the best thing right it's the best job
ever
i could be a role too [ __ ] yeah you know
i don't say that but it's singling on
this [ __ ] it's not wrestling you know
what i'm saying
okay i'm working a baseball game one
minute i'm making a shirt one minute um
you know what i'm saying saving the
little kids work the rest of the shoes
put this
i'm in a high speed chase yeah i love
that [ __ ] yeah
that's so dope i couldn't believe that
dude the other day who pulled up on us
you're like here comes the hammer
remember that dude yeah remember in the
alley yeah oh we're not just talking
about that
yeah
i remember that [ __ ] yeah i was like
yes every day yeah yo
it's crazy seriously bro 100 yes
no disrespect no disrespect to any
municipal this is the training round
this is like the forefront of policing
if you want to be a cop like what
obviously
yeah your big cities but you want real
some real [ __ ] where like a sergeant
would walk in the room and be like
yo jay yo yo
we're gonna hit a door come through and
like you showed up to work and like i'm
getting ready to write reports and then
it's like boom boom boom you know
somebody like kg you show up hey we're
doing a federal
right
and it's like
[ __ ]
this is what i'm about to do you get
that experience
i love it man i love you all man love
you more bro
i wish i had something simple
hey god bless both of you man bless you
man thank you for uh
i want us to talk to you come on dog
come on we're talking that [ __ ] it's a
privilege no it's an honor just to be
here bro yo shout out to this beautiful
space you know what i'm saying word out
shout out shout out to my sexy crotch
you know what i'm saying we're walking
with the hot socks
so we're back chronicles podcast we love
you we appreciate you dude shout out to
my brother
john berthold
real once all day appreciate y'all
silverback dog silver real ones real
ones all day what's that that's a
phenomenal real world team
yeah shout out to the real ones network
we love you guys oh yeah oh yeah listen
silverback chronicles podcast we love
you we working
listen if there's anything you want to
see we are real active detectives we do
this we're here to help we hit a
brisbane community bridge the gap from
police it's not just about police it's
about everybody everybody has a voice
that needs to be heard
and we have that platform and we want
you to come in and say you know say your
peace and we love you
shout out to everybody podcasting shout
out to you know people doing something
positive with a platform
because yo we need more positivity in
this world absolutely [ __ ] all that
negative [ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ] about
no colors yo let's let's let's get to
the solution let's hug each other and
let's love each other and that's it man
and i reason why i say we're the number
one law enforcement podcast because we
are [ __ ] ain't talking the way
we talk the swag is different they're
individual everything is there you know
hey shout out to bpd shout out to the
baltimore police department this
wonderful community that has taken me in
oh i love you oh i love you yo shout out
to bart's on this man then listen to all
that [ __ ] y'all
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff uh it'd mean a lot to
us i hope you dig these episodes as much
as we dig doing them you guys take care
of yourself